hello welcome back to the YouTube gaming
stage right here at PAX Prime 2015 I'm
Tonya dwyer from gamespot com delighted
to be joined by two of the most
prominent youtuber especially in a
Minecraft world sky hey do my friends I
sparkles were going to open air five BAM
kill net and welcome to pax have you
guys come here every single year like is
this a big deal floor if you're in the
area right through every every year I go
to prime Boston I didn't I miss the UH
was Australia house now south south oh
yeah I thought then it's real sad yeah
there was one in Australia wasn't there
yeah yeah I missed that one too well no
that's later this year is it yeah it was
it not one before there was a glass here
oh yeah yeah I hit up that one in San
Antonio did you hit I did I've not been
very good in going to conventions this
year very occupied with projects but
happy to be here yeah you're a busy man
you're like I closing on a house in like
24 then I finished that today so that's
exciting yeah they must have been super
jazzed that you were coming to her
conventions they weren't really happy
when I mentioned I was going out of town
there yeah you picked kind of the worst
time I was like it was booked before I
was buying this house sorry how you
joined the show so forth it's good I got
to play some minecraft story mode still
oh I'm jelly i didn't i didn't get to do
that yet I'm sure if you walked over
there there would be kind enough to
accommodate you think I think they're
like oh hey how's it going if they don't
you can bring your massive oh well just
bring the plaque hey come on my
admission ticket ever that's like if you
need to get into a club and it's like
VIP you just carry that thing every man
I'd be so ripped by the end of it yeah
it's so heavy arms be amazing have you
seen the mine craft store on the
entrance and we're at 4°c is pretty cool
like replica one just that over there
that like made a fake one and so what
did you think about story mode mm I
thought it was very cool it was slightly
from the trailer that I saw I thought it
was it looked very much like a minecraft
animation the Yaffe on YouTube and when
I plated it seemed a little bit more
like Minecraft II more like the game
itself and it
I liked it I don't want to spoil
anything but there was a very cool
monster okay monster in it so a unique
monster their unique months okay I like
it it's hero Brian in it there was no
Arab right thing all right wait it's
like a new monster you'll have to go in
but yeah that's finally for people your
cheer channel for ever had like we're
really good animations like that was
like one of your focus is out of like
seeing them kind of basically make a
game out of what you were essentially
doing on youtube / I mean I don't know I
I don't know if they took any
inspiration from what myself or any
other animators have done on YouTube
maybe but I guess you know when it comes
to Minecraft and making it animated
there's only so much you can do as far
as a side up so anyway oh I'll happily
think that maybe they took some
inspiration but who knows smidge of
credit I learned it and it's been like a
goddess the six years prompting 09 since
I guess it like sort of came out came
out for everyone and what what's it like
now being playing minecraft in like
twenty fifty like what the latest patch
has come out like what's what's the
ecosystem for people think my craft
right now is it very much the sort of
similar type of stuff that people were
doing like two years ago or has it
changed a lot recently though I mean a
lot Microsoft kind of thing a lot of
stuff has evolved over the years
obviously but yeah I guess they finally
just after the whole acquisition just
got back into releasing new content
updates for pc and i think that their
goal is to bring every platform sort of
to be the same game rather than it being
one thing on pocket one thing you see so
it'll be interesting to see how they
work that all together yeah because that
xbox one fan base and xbox 360 as well
edition did really really well I are you
seeing that there's a huge huge huge
community for like Pocket Edition as
well yeah like I saw people were getting
like millions and millions of
use on just pocket edition I had no idea
it's crazy you playing much yourself uh
no I never had a chance to really play
that much Pocket Edition I'd of those
like new blocks and different flowers
but that's that's I'm probably just
insulted the entire pocket community
just outside of a Minecraft what are you
playing at the moment like wanted again
I'm in about this year so I have another
channel called sky versus gaming where I
play a lot of GTA gmod happy wheels
pretty much indie games as well and I've
been having a blast with that because
it's a it's fun playing Minecraft and
everything but it's also good to take a
little bit of a break yeah and play some
other games as well palate cleanser I
remember you did a bunch of grand theft
auto 5 stuff as well like kind of yeah I
gave me a year ago remember those logs
I've done yeah and then when the pc
dropped i did a little bit more it's
always fun to do occasionally especially
i'd like to do more co-op missions with
people because i haven't gotten too far
into the heist but yeah pretty fun so
maybe give that a try and also like
garry's mod the games that he's guy just
said garry's mod it's so fun yeah just
you can do so many different things yeah
it's a game that will never end yeah
it's like it's like it's like a
different form of minecraft i'm kinda
i'm older as well that's like 2005 I
think of us and then it just re surged
again yeah for real huh I think like a
whole new generation just figured it out
I take because of youtubers actually I
think that's probably where the whole
thing surface and excited outhouse how's
your game going you launched it yeah I
know you're doing some sort of like
funding but it's not like it's like
we're doing instead of like a
Kickstarter which is essentially like
more based on donation yeah a good tip
jar an equity crowdfunding around so
people are actually investing getting
shares in the company that's what we're
doing for our game we'll see how it
turns out when we completed all
hopefully in a couple months and but
it's exciting it's great book guys about
keeping as super busy and what I want to
do before you go is like you people come
to the game spot and people watch you
too because they want to like find out
about the games that they should be
playing so for both of you if you could
pick one game that you've seen maybe a
packs or
you've been playing for the past couple
of months or that you're looking forward
to it's coming out later this year want
to be like the sort of the one game you
say to people to like keep an eye on you
first got oh god you had to make me
first ah on the spot honestly I I don't
know uh I'm a nintendo nerd all right
that's just it they've got they've got a
marketer's say that Mario maker oh yeah
cuz I think that's going to create an
entire community I haven't looked at
that admittedly but I mean I guess for
me every time that the dota 2
international tournament heightens I'm
always like I have to play more dota
right here haven't I haven't had much
time lately to do it and so 18 million
dollar tournament gets me excited I need
that I need to get back into playing it
again you know once you've got the house
sort of that you'll probably find a
bunch more time you didn't have for a
while there so perfectly yeah test out
your Wi-Fi pleasant odor conference
Marco scaia thank you both so much for
coming on I have a pleasure to talk to
you both and enjoy the rest of your
packs experience
you